yeah one thing i was going to ask is
like because you know
compared to
you youtube boomers right here we are
like we are very much children oh yeah
nine years seven years right seven years
yeah like i just discovered what boogers
taste
so it's like
what i wanted to ask uh you specifically
is like
how much of longevity do you see
as a youtuber being a career right
because it's like we don't really have
any like you know because like it's say
of like you know hollywood or like the
acting industry or music industry right
yeah we already have examples of people
who have had careers for like
30 40 50 years yes right but because
youtube is such a new thing whereas like
i think the longest is probably someone
like you right it's like do you see
yourself doing this for the next 10 15
years again i mean it's already been
half my life yeah so it feels
like i can give my confidence to the
idea that youtube will be around for a
long time right they haven't made any
glaring mistakes that are still glaring
mistakes like it feels like they've made
a ton of mistakes absolutely i'm not
gonna write them off completely
but it seems like over time they are
remedying a lot of those it feels like
they actually are caring about the
community i'm not you know there's
plenty of issues but
it seems like
enough people care to make changes to
keep the platform relevant right because
like it's a gun
i completely lost it
because obviously people are going to be
like what do you mean
yeah and it's like i think as you were
saying as a whole platform i think they
they meant considering the amount of
[ __ ] that goes on the platform yeah yeah
they do a pretty good job at keeping it
relevant pushing it forward and and
making it the place yeah yeah obviously
there's this place yeah because i think
definitely like the the one moment that
youtube like did a [ __ ] and everyone
was like this is the end of youtube was
when demonetization became a thing right
yeah and the ad apocalypse came out
everyone unanimously was like this is it
this is where this is where it dies yeah
but it somehow managed to stick around
for what five extra years that that
needed to happen though yeah looking
back at it it was an inevitability that
it was gonna come to something like that
yeah a system like that was going to
have to be played yeah they implemented
a lot of things that help with that
though like on the back end you can
upload a video now and it'll say
um i'm not sure if it's for everyone i
think
so what i will say is when i upload a
video it says uh checking
yeah and then after a half hour 45
minutes an hour or whatever it
eventually does like the initial check
and then you can have some confidence
yeah that it probably caught it if it's
going to catch something that you
shouldn't have in the video yeah so that
has given me a lot of confidence in the
direction of that because monetization
was a huge issue every time i would
upload for a while i was like um i don't
know let's see this thing i put tens of
thousands of dollars into
it might
be worth nothing i might just be in the
red for this right they did fix some
things i feel and they're slowly but
surely i think fixing a lot of the
glaring issues yeah was there like a
point where like this changed from you
know because
as with the way being a content creator
is this changed from being a job
to a career because like for the longest
time i treated youtube as a job because
you wake up and you're like maybe i'll
be irrelevant nick tomorrow a week from
now a year and like i didn't really feel
like this was a career literally until
this podcast when i'm just like oh okay
this is like a business sustainable
business that i can see myself
you know five ten years in the future is
that was there a point for that for you
i think the moment that that changes
with somebody in general is probably
when you have a format that you know you
can come back to and feel confident in
and that's probably why this podcast was
like we know the format yeah yeah you
know it's kind of all figured out so
that it feels like this is a repeating
thing yeah um for me it was
i think it probably felt like career
when i mean when we were purchased by
defy because right right right we had
salary and salary i mean that that kind
of i feel like is unique to me though
yeah um but then
after that you know going off
independently the moment that it felt
like a career for me now was when i had
a series i spent a day with to go back
to yeah yeah i knew that it was a
repeating like a safety net like some
something comfort you know i think
that's the difference yeah when it when
you know that you have something you're
not starting from square one every
single video yeah you know a lot of
people are still trying to figure out
what they're doing so every single video
is back to the drawing board and that
just feels like a job and trust me it's
tough yeah because like i feel like when
you're starting off on youtube you want
to make like every video like a 10 out
of 10 banger you want to be motivated
you want to do something new every time
then you realize that after a year or
two of doing it you're like this is not
sustainable that's all i need i need
some kind of formula that i can fall
back on because i can't always be you
know at my peak of creativity every time
yeah yeah so you guys are like 90
probably going into each episode 90 sure
where things are going to go you know
and that that
yeah
yeah well going back to the beginning of
this semester right
well roughly
you know a little bit about what the
dynamic is going to be like okay i know
if i say this thing maybe or maybe he'll
react
your face is not so short
i'm like all i know is that we're gonna
have someone on the show and we're gonna
be talking about their stuff well you
have a name and you have sponsors yeah
exactly exactly yeah
yeah i guess like sorry no it's just
saying like i feel like in in a weird
way
we're still trying to figure out that
formula for trash taste in in a sense
it's like we've kind of figured it out
you know it's obviously like a lot
hundred episodes
deep right but it's like i'm i'm
personally always like yeah you know
scared of like that that moment where it
starts to get repetitive or stuff they
feel like a job and like luckily it's i
i don't feel that way right now about it
but it's like i am scared to like fall
into that so what are you doing to
prevent it from feeling like it's a
repetitive job oh i mean we're bringing
it on tour now
i mean we're yeah we're filming overseas
we're getting you know all sorts of
interesting guests and stuff like that
and i think the specials definitely help
yeah uh where that's like that's the
moment where we can just like kind of
really explode with our creativity also
those specials probably are what excite
the audience as well right yeah yeah
yeah i hope so
right guys
every now and then so i'll be like
where's our four-hour conversation i
wanted to go to work and listen to four
hours
one hour of content yeah yeah
yeah i guess like my final question is
what do you want to do in the future i
mean you've been on the platform 17
years yeah is there something for your
20th anniversary
got nothing planned man but 21st you
don't know
um
i think i mean i just want to continue
refining what i do
that's what i've been enjoying doing
most uh this i spent a day with series
has been so fun for me because every
single
every single episode i see
at least one element that i want to
refine whether it's the lighting on the
set or something that's like really um
technical like that or it's like my
uh
performance on the interest feels like
i'm just reading words i'm gonna you
know revamp that and try to learn it or
like
i i just went all out i did these tests
where i reshot some of my intros
where i have a jib
like right which is like a [ __ ]
little crane yeah onto a camera and i
was like what if i because i was
watching a bunch of really big youtubers
you know like erect for example right
yeah and i was like
he has these intros where he's like
choreographed this scene
um there's one that he either like about
like
what would you do if you had one day
left right so he starts off and it's
like the doctor's saying you have one
day left to live and he's like in these
bandages and then he's like he just gets
up and he gets out and the doctor's like
where are you going and he's like
ripping off his bandages stuff he's like
talking about the camera and he's like
what would you do if you had one day
left and he's like
to the audience and he's bringing us
through the cameras like following him
and it's like this choreographed scene
that
just immediately right off the bat you
know
there was this effort that went into
this this is a good setup for this video
because i know that if the rest of this
video is like anything like these first
30 seconds it's gonna be so much fun
yeah so i was like how could i apply
some of these things that i'm seeing
modern youtubers do right uh and apply
it to an interview format i was like i
can kind of choreograph the way that i
say these things so i'm still learning
with that and
so it's hard to say like where i want to
go next but
i think more importantly i know
where i want to go now and that's to
constantly refine and not allow myself
to get bored because i want to always
creatively
see where what is like right out of my
comfort zone it's really cool that
you've been on youtube for that long
yeah i still want to get inspiration
that's very humbling yeah like it's it's
inspiring to hear that like you are
still on your journey right
yeah after 70 yeah after 17 years you're
still on your journey and you're still
figuring stuff out yeah because in my
head i was like damn i've been doing
this [ __ ] for nine years i don't know
what the [ __ ] i'm doing i'm glad to know
someone who's been doing it for almost
double that also doesn't know wow you're
not having fun man it's yeah
if i'm if i enjoy what i'm doing like i
feel like that is the best career that
you could have yeah that's where you
enjoy it not not the career that you
know unfolds in this timeline that i
pre-built in my head for where it goes
right yeah yeah you hear that guys it's
not about the money
it's about the love for it but yeah
thank you so much for coming on
this is awesome